[Music]
Taron Egerton in richard madden giving
Elton the carpool karaoke treatment and
Taryn takes it next level I think you
should maybe change you can watch the
full episode on Apple TV we are just
waiting for Beyonce to get there by the
way happy birthday Elton John he turned
72 today and he celebrated by revealing
the cover of his first autobiography it
is out in October meanwhile Taryn and
Richard of bringing Elton's life story
to the big screen in Rocket Man in only
I went behind the scenes in London
[Music]
you've been seeing for a long time this
isn't a new thing no no I mean started
off his shower singing and became
drunken singing and now I'm kind of
doing it as part of my acting life which
is great but you don't care you'll sing
anywhere yeah yeah I mean anyone who
knows and loves me a truly truly sick
and tired of hearing we're singing a
hymn listen taryn's being modest Sir
Elton hand-picked him for Rocket Man
Elton said he loves your voice he loves
what you're doing with the songs thanks
oh well on the London set complete with
a recreated troubadour theatre I got a
chance to check out the costume trailer
I can tell you no expense was spared in
recreating sir Elton's iconic looks
the Dodger outfit is heavy
yeah rule is that light wearing that I
mean the phrase first world problem
springs to mind but yeah when it looks
back fabulous it look you kind of you
forget how do you feel when you get in
it do you kind of feel that Elton vibe
were you kind of like it's definitely
empowering yeah you kind of thinking she
the swaggering kind of stage persona
think so how does it feel to be a star
significant at last
[Music]